so should I start enjoying these with
winter is here the winds of winter Game
of Thrones season 6 episode 10 season
finale whoa this will not be a spoiler
free review and actually you really
can't talk about this episode without
getting into spoilers pretty much right
off the bat boom that was I that was an
impressive way to open the episode you
know with this really extended dealing
with all the stuff in King's Landing and
the trial and to end it really actually
kind of hurt having to watch lancel go
through that and to see his family
they're getting out you all torn up
having to watch it and then i know i'm
watching this going okay it's kind of
interesting where are we going with this
and you know it's got grand maester
pycelle being led away and then Loras
being led by that boy and for a little
while I'm going I don't know where we're
going but I'm really interested which is
a tricky thing to pull off because a lot
of times when you don't know where
something's going you're like where is
this going and you're just annoyed but
this I was like I know where we're going
but take me there and who I did you know
I figured I figure that but I think when
most people probably figure the minute
you saw those barrels leaking green it
was all crap seriously is not messing
around and honestly I think more than
the fact that she blew that place up and
killed who knows how many people she
obviously doesn't care I think what
showed me much more just how far gone
she is kids are killing these people now
it could be arguable that it sky burn
making the call that the kids are
executing folks and maybe Searcy doesn't
know but she has to have a pretty good
idea with this guy's up to and then to
cap another surprises all that thomann
out the window did not see that one
coming in a lot of ways and narrative
Lee and thematically it's a move that
makes a lot of sense because if we've
only got 13 episodes left in the show
that's what the word is right now when
regardless of whether they break that up
into two seasons or not if that's all
we've got left the thing needs to really
focus it's got
cut the fat cut the deadweight focus on
the things that really matter and
honestly you know things the the
squabbling is over who was control of
King's Landing that's that's a small
pond we were seeing who's gonna be the
big fish in a small pond we got to clear
that deck and just crown somebody the
big fish so that we can deal with the
bigger picture and like that makes a
whole lot of sense I'm still really
sorry to see so many storylines get
closed out in one fell swoop they're you
know the high Sparrow boom the Tyrells
well not all of them will get back to
lady Elaina brand Meister pycelle gone
you know what it had it was really well
done which took the sting off at a lab
it because I think the one I miss more
than anything is is gonna be Marjorie I
was sorry to see her go because I like
her as a presence I wanted her to get
yeah I wanted her to get something
because she would she I mean she not
only does she play the game so well but
she was giving up so much as sacrificing
so much to get on the right side of the
high Sparrow and to just die anyway it's
kind of sad but the the what took the
sting off all that for me is the whole
thing just really rang the bell of the
Godfather and Michael Corleone just
having all of his competition executed
you know while he's in church and it had
that same sort of slow but you're just
watching these horrible things unfold in
this very matter-of-fact kind of slow
methodical fashion I'm just gonna run
through his best again I'm probably
gonna forget some of the stuff that
happened cuz they would God there was so
much that went on here what I mentioned
Lady Elaine is so door now when we when
the thing went to do action you know
what skip that when Doran showed up in
the previously on game of thrones
segment my immediate thought was Thorne
who cares about door I do not care about
darling honestly I still don't but they
managed to tie not one but two
characters who I really like and don't
care about into that storyline so now I
am accepting of Dorne coming back
because we got lady Ilena lover we got
Varys love him okay you've given me
enough things that I really care about
and tied them to this thing that okay
this will probably work plus that seems
that appears to put them on the
side of Daenerys and her whole force so
now we've kind of got basically three
factions going on as well as you know
the big climax that we're going to be
dealing with so we've got seriously and
whatever forces she has basically camped
out at King's Landing I actually I don't
have a really strong sense of what kind
of force she actually has behind her at
this point she looks good on that throne
though but there's one faction you've
got the north which is jon snow and all
those other houses and that Oh Lady
Mormont that little girl she's awesome
she's only had two noted scenes all
she's great and yet I wish I could say
this was my idea but some of the the
people who I talked to about these
episodes you know sort of as they air
you know they said oh how great would it
be if she ends up on the Iron Throne kid
weeks till we start hashtagging petition
that or something lady Mormont on the
Iron Throne I don't know so there's your
infection then there's Denarius in all
her side so you've got you've got these
three factions some of which might end
up t me I mean seriously is the one with
no friends at this point she's kind of
screwed next year because she's got
opposition up north that may not
actively be coming after her but
certainly isn't gonna help her when
Daenerys come steaming through across
the sea she's finally crossing that sea
thank God I feel like Tyrion was voicing
the audience when he was like you
believe this is actually happening I'm
like yes been waiting for its avid for
six seasons yes I can believe it thank
God are you taking that Walder Frey that
was nice when she pulled the face off
yeah I part of my brain did go well when
did she steal a face when the Faceless
Men be pissed her who cares it's awesome
and I knew something was I mean the
minute I saw him in there alone by
himself online mmm something's up and
the minute that girl said your sons are
already here like up there in the pie so
I felt like I was ahead of this until
she pulled the face off and there's aria
yeah all gotten the look on her face
when she cut his throat who do not get
her angry speaking of stark ladies props
to San sup for basically in her own
subtle ladylike way telling little
finger to go screw himself I am oddly
still glad
he's around I like him as a sort of a
wild card in all this knowing that he
wants to put his own butt on the throne
ultimately speaking of the starts Ned
little Ned in flashback and we finally
got the backstory not a huge shock there
if you follow fan theory at all then
this was been the long-running the most
popular and the most likely theory about
John's identity in who John's actual
parents were but they executed that
reveal very very well it could have been
really clunky and I could have been
sitting there going yeah yeah I know I
know I know but to go from the baby's
eyes to John's I bet classy like it I
really like the world that Tyrion has
settled into he I don't I feel like he's
never really gonna get highlighted the
way that he did in some earlier seasons
but you know that's just kind of how it
is he's he's the little guy he's not
gonna be the main focus and like I said
we're heading into the final stretch of
this show we're gonna be dealing with
the big big stuff and Tyrion yeah he has
an impact on the big stuff but he will
never be the central focus of it so I
feel like this season is kind of
impressing to us like this is where he
is now right okay fine cool then I was
leaving Dario behind I feel like that
was a little more drawn out than it
needed to be big i mean just large
because maybe I don't care about Daario
naharis I don't know if I'm one of many
or if I'm alone on that but that felt a
little bit drawn out that said the
follow-up seen with her interior work 12
who I think that's about everything Oh
Davos and lady Melisandre that was a
nice confrontation I really was a child
I was gonna play out but I I was very
happy to see him a rage against her and
to see John kind of back him like not in
not necessarily as harshly as strictly
sa Ned might've but you know still no
he's right you did wrong get out I think
that's about everything this was a
really good finale and it was a really
good finale for not being a big
whiz-bang smash finish a lot of the
finales in this show many times it'd
they're very subdued because they
usually have the really big sort of epic
stuff happened the episode before which
was actually the case here because we
had the Battle of the bastards but
there's so much stuff going on there's
so much stuff to wrap up here that it
this does not feel like just going oh
and we're just going to tie a few things
up until next season know this would big
stuff big things happen big shake ups
and it really does lay the groundwork
and sort of the lay of the land for next
season which boy yes that's gonna be a
long wait I'm not sure where I would
write this season overall in terms of
the other I think I think its upper half
for me I think it makes the the top
three as opposed to the bottom three
million my bottom two are easy to call
season three's my least favorite then
its season five season four is still my
favorite season one after that whether
this one beats out to for that number
three spot I don't know I could go right
now I'm going to say yes this takes
third spot season 2 takes on fourth spot
so i guess i can't figure out how I'm
gonna write them so that's my own
ranking so what were your thoughts on
this episode on the season overall how
does the whole thing rank how excited
are you for what's coming next what do
you think whatever it is drop something
down the comments and let's talk about
it please give a give a like a subscribe
follow me on twitter i counsel of geeks
check out the council of weeks podcast
on iTunes and stitcher an until next
time this council is adjourned hashtag
lady more monta on the Iron Throne